tout commence en février 2021 lorsque
l'écrivaine florence porcel porte
plainte pour viol contre patrick poivre
d'arvor patrick poivre d'arvor est visé
par une enquête pour viol si cette
affaire est classée sans suite le
journaliste va quelques mois plus tard
être accusée par d'autres femmes une
vingtaine au total je rentrais dans le
bureau le téléphone a sonné cinq minutes
après j'avais son sexe dans ma bouche et
la paix rhdp pda prend encore de
l'ampleur lorsque le journal libération
publié hier soir une enquête explosive
libération publie de nouvelles
accusations contre ppda trois femmes
témoignent ses trois nouvelles victimes
présumées sont toutes écrivaine et
aurait parfois été abusé dans le bureau
du présentateur parmi elle bénédicte
martin qui affirme que ces faits
n'auraient pas été pris au sérieux par
sa maison d'édition il tourne autour
d'elle et alors qu'il est derrière la
saisie par la gorge en lui faisant une
clef avec le bras ne remonte sa jupe il
embrasse cette enquête fait écho au
livre choc d'hélène devynck est sur le
point de paraître et qui pointe la
responsabilité de tf1 dans un viol
qu'elle ait d'autres victimes pourraient
subi ce soir on revient sur les toutes
dernières révélations de la terre ppda
dans un instant bénédicte martin
nouvelle nouvelle nous vos témoignages
voilà qui sera avec nous un instant
journaliste écrivaine voilà elle va
témoigner de ce qui s'est passé et pour
elle aussi une complicité du showbiz
inde en se pendant dans cette affaire
florian scène merci d'être avec nous sur
quoi et le livre impunité parle de quoi
comment le livre un plus ici de bah en
fait c'est elle revient déjà sur sa
propre histoire parce que l'aisne de
l'eure examen quinquas et et qui a été
violée et agressée sexuellement par
patrick poivre d'arvor en 93 et dans son
livre en fait elle fait deux choses
particulièrement elle dénonce l'inaction
de tf1 à l'époque mais encore
aujourd'hui elle dit quoi sur tf1 parce
que et en quoi en quoi la direction de
tf1 qu est ce qu elle leur reproche la
elle leur reproche notamment de déployer
le côté la thèse de la vieille affaire
vous savez le côté la stratégie de
l'ignorance du mépris dans un premier
temps et puis ensuite de faire comme si
tf1 donc n'avait pas à ramener son
agresseur que ce soit au terme de deux
cadres de statut mais aussi de moyens
elle dit qu elle dit qu'elle dit que la
terre et la direction de téléphone qu'on
reconnaît pas sa responsabilité
gilles elle dit évidemment tf1 était
responsable web des mots très forts
pourquoi elle dit il y a eu un système
criminel qui a fonctionné dans un
environnement qu'il permettait et de se
poser la question pourquoi cet
environnement le permettait faire
classer directement ciblés tf1 qui
aurait en quelque sorte permis ou les
cerfs et ppda couvert ppda dans ses
actes potentiellement criminel donc
c'est très fort ce qu'elle dit vraiment
c'est la première fois que directement
tf1 est pointée du doigt à ce point
alors qu'est ce qui empêche les
dirigeants de tf1 de de s'adresser
aujourd'hui aux victimes et de parler
emploi bah en fait il ya plusieurs
choses déjà tf1 n'est pas responsable
pénalement en tout cas jusqu'à preuve du
contraire de ce qui s'est passé donc eu
à travers notamment gilles pélisson a
trente tf1 bah voilà ils brandissent un
petit peu le côté
pas vu pas pris à l'époque le côté
crimes prescrits si la crème encore une
fois parce qu'on parle de viol présumée
puisqu'il n'a pas été condamné donc tf1
se réfugie derrière ça il ya aussi un
truc très important c'est le 7 à 8 de
l'an dernier du 2 décembre 2021 c'est à
dire qu'en fait tf1 aurait un peu fait
ça bea à travers cette a8 en gros
c'était un message tf1 lâche ppda permet
de nombreux témoignages à une heure de
grande écoute sur leur antenne sur
laquelle il a officié pendant pendant le
temps de deux décennies donc voilà tf1
s'abrite derrière ça et pour l'instant
attends attends qu il ya des éléments
plus plus fragiles fruits tf1 dit nous
ne savions pas à l'époque nous n'avions
pas conscience de ces faits et ils
disent aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
politique de tolérance zéro il ya une
sorte de distorsion c'est à dire on ne
savait pas à l'époque et aujourd'hui
tolérance zéro aujourd'hui vraiment le
le le silence assourdissant de tf1 par
rapport aux victimes commencent à poser
problème judiciairement il ne risque
rien mais moralement ça commence
vraiment être très loose qui qu'est ce
qui leur est reproché d'avoir d'avoir
derrière couvrir les
raids aériens dit et comment le
savez-vous ne pas savoir alors que ça se
déroule à chaque fois dans les
témoignages et après le journal on est
heureux on est invité au 20 heures il se
passa on va dans un bureau qui est à
côté donc comment les responsables de
tf1 où les proches de ppda aurait pu ne
pas savoir aurait pu ne pas entendre
voilà c'est ça qui pose problème je
pense que ce que raconte hélène de vin
et dans son livre et qu'on savait déjà
quand même de but depuis un moment c'est
qu'effectivement l'été les dirigeants de
tf1 est le journaliste de tf1 sont
jamais cachés est de savoir qui se
passait des choses dans le bureau de
patrick poivre d'arvor en revanche ils
ont toujours nié le fait de savoir qui
avait agressions viols
parfois éventuellement menace je ne sais
quoi qui permettait à patrick poivre
d'arvor de développer une forme
d'emprise sur les femmes qui venaient
voir ce que c'est toujours le même le
même stratagème et venez voir son jt
après l'arrivée dans son bureau a mené
par son assistante avec qui travaille
encore aujourd'hui c'était toujours le
même piège qui se refermait en tout cas
de façon présumé sur elle et c'est ce
qu'elle dénonce et par ailleurs les
dirigeants de l'époque sont décédés donc
c'est compliqué de les convoquer nous y
voilà après voilà après oui gilles c'est
vrai que qu'est ce qu'ils lisent à ça
alors ce qui est très vrai dans ce que
vient de dire florian c'est le côté
répétitif et ça c'est vraiment la
nouveauté par rapport à tout ce qui est
sorti aujourd'hui également c'est que si
jamais il ya répétition de fait
d'agression sexuelle ou de viol par un
même homme avec le même mode opératoire
est dans les mêmes locaux quasiment à
chaque fois fin très souvent même bureau
tf1 ça s'apparenterait à une série et si
jamais c'est une série à ce moment là
quelles que soient les dates il n'y a
plus de prescription cette fameuse
prescription qui fait qu'on peut pas
poursuivre si on prouve que la wii la
série et c'est ce que la justice tente
de faire voir la répétition
avaient
le même mode opératoire les mêmes lieux
une série a pas de prescription et là
éventuellement il pourrait y avoir un
procès de filles est intéressant avec ce
que vient de recettes de sorte à la fois
le livre d'hélène devynck est ce que
vient de sortir une libération alors
justement bahwan on va avoir une
relation témoignages et que bénédicte
martin dans un instant avec nous via clé
le présumé de ppda will est juste en
train d'étudier le systématisme de cm2
ses affaires le côté sérielle et c'est
le caractère sériel est avérée là c'est
une façon de contourner la prescription
et à ce moment là on devrait devoir
avoir à répondre que des gens les saints
incroyable c'est le comportement de ppda
face à toutes ces accusations il fait
quasiment comme si de rien n'était ils
continuent d'apparaître publiquement il
faisait encore partie du jury d'un
concours sur le rayonnement de la france
ya pas longtemps et on sait que d'en
faire quoi alors il doit faire quoi
qu'il faille dans un lycée parce qu'à
chaque fois qu'il apparaît ses prix
comme une provocation par les victimes
présumées qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux à témoigner et on parlait il ya
pas longtemps de nicolas hulot qui lui a
choisi de se murer dans le silence pour
éviter un scénario à la ppda c'est
peut-être ce qui nous réveille parce
qu'à chaque fois qu'il parle à chaque
fois qu'il apparaît ça agace et sa tenue
à de nouveaux témoignages ce qui est
intéressant pour aller dans le sens de
guillaume ii ce qui est raconté dans le
livre d'hélène devynck c'est que c'est
un petit peu la victime qui parle aux
victimes parce qu'en gros c'est une
succession de portraits des victimes pas
tout mais en tout cas un grand nombre
qui racontent leur calvaire pendant mais
aussi après avec la peur le silence
parfois l'anorexie pour certaines qui
ont elles mêmes un raconte qu'elle
encore aujourd'hui elle est traumatisée
par parce qu'elle a vécu donc c'est ça
qui est vraiment très fort c'est dans le
journal l'aube ce qui est qui et que
tout ça est racontée et très sincèrement
on se rend compte en tout cas que toutes
les plaintes se ressemblent au niveau du
jeu marc vécu pendant mais aussi après
alors justement on va accueillir
bénédicte martin qui a témoigné avec
deux autres nouvelles victimes présumées
de ppda d'amp et dans libération
aujourd'hui violences agressions
sexuelles complicité du showbiz
bénédicte elle était avec nous pour nous
livrer son témoignage concernant
l'agression sexuelle dont elle a été
victime bénédicte nous rejoint tout de
suite merci bénédicte de venir nous
rejoindre merci bénédicte et la merci
beaucoup à prouver
merci alors merci bénédicte merci d'être
là merci merci installez vous installez
vous merci venez dit bénédicte
merci encore d'être là alors on est en
direct oui ça va tout va bien vous êtes
contents de carrière va merci en tout
cas d'être là ça va tu sais rien c'est
un petit réglage est là pour ça
merci merci beaucoup d'être la vinadie
vous avez porté plainte le 12 septembre
contre ppda vous dénoncez une agression
sexuelle survenue en novembre 2003 dans
le bureau de l'animateur
alors vous êtes journaliste et écrivaine
toujours les mêmes profils d'ailleurs
est-ce que c'est sûrement les
journaliste et écrivaine
bénédicte qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est serré que c'est la question qu'on
pose à chaque fois mais c'est vrai
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait
qu'est-ce que ce qui s'est passé oui le
jour à la wii en novembre 2003 avant
2003 j'ai sorti mon premier livre chez
flammarion
du coup un recueil de nouvelles
érotiques
j'étais jeune un grosse promotion j'ai
été invité à l'émission vol de nuit
chiquita leurs vols de nuit j'étais très
grosse émission littéraire sur tf1 qui
est passé aux alentours de 23h30 oui
c'est ça voilà exactement qui tourne au
troisième entre la deuxième et la
troisième partie de soirée oui donc
c'était ppda qui présentait vol de nuit
exactement voilà les missions soit se
déroule correctement
après il y a
un petit aparté après l'émission comme
ça où tout le monde s'est réuni
l'émission se tournent de se tourner
dans les locaux de tf1
j'avais pu voir celui-ci accord c'est
prévu je sais plus
non je ne crois pas que c'était d'accord
nous avons l'émission de vous voyez vous
voilà et est en fête
voilà un petit peu de manière informelle
comme ça après l'émission espèce de
débrief général et patrick poivre
d'arvor vient vers moi c'est donc me
félicite
la limite de la flagornerie je suis
fantastique j'écris très très bien et il
me dit que il aimerait énormément me
revoir qu'il aime bien accompagner les
jeunes auteurs grâce à son poids dans
gens dans le milieu littéraire son
émission et tout ça vous êtes tout est
édité chez flammarion le livre a
énormément de promo donc forcément c'est
vrai voilà on se dit vous êtes voilà
c'est vrai que le livre est très bien
perçu voilà pour l'instant vous dit non
il n'y a pas de technologie voilà c'est
presque logique ou alors oui
donc
ma foi il me dit qu'il aimerait beaucoup
le revoir et que les créneaux qui hélas
sont
après le jt est ce que ça m'intéresse de
venir voir le jt
donc moi je franchement
j'ai pas vraiment grandi avec la télé
patrick poivre d'arvor n'a jamais
fasciné
donc je m'en fous un peu c'est drôle ça
ado je vous demande si tu ajoutes et non
franchement je m'en fous total mais
total non mais c'est vrai mais c'est ça
sa irai je redis pareil moi
et je vois mon attachée de presse en
l'occurrence donc patrick me parlait
pendant qu'il me parlait et voilà je
fais pas la main en même temps et je
vois mon attachée de presse qui est
derrière lui un moment que j'ai dit dès
qu'il me fait des pouces levés comme ça
si si si tu reviens vas-y blanchir et
donc je dis oui d'accord donc voilà on
prend rendez vous pour que j'allais
assister au jt et par la suite après le
jt et nous échangions sur ma carrière
bien sûr voilà donc là c'est après votre
premier livre ça c'est en novembre 2003
et forcément voilà après warm up donc
vous y allez vous êtes invités à venir
le voir au jt de tf1 pour l'instant vous
senti aucun danger avant d'y aller un
nom après je vais trouver son intérêt un
petit peu
un petit peu un petit peu démesuré quoi
je suis pas
je pense génie non plus quoi je le dirai
et châteaubriant
aussi besoin c'est si évident mais c'est
vrai que le livre il y avait eu
énormément de promo les journaux on
avait énormément parler donc alors vous
voulez admiriez pas plus que ça à
l'époque non vraiment c'était pas non
donc vous y allez quand même au jt oui
par curiosité vous y allez donc ces
procès où vous y aller tranquille vous
allez tout seul oui j'y vais tout seul
ce que votre attaché de presse comme le
bowling aurélie elle aurait pu venir
avec vous non non non on n'est pas venu
et donc je vais pas mes propres moyens
j'arrive une assistante
me fait monter donc à l'état joue il ya
le studio là on installe
sous la caméra à côté du prompteur et
il se passe à peu près 20 minutes avant
la prise d'antenne ou des gens en fait
divers viennent me parler comme voilà le
staff autour et voir où je mets mes
affaires et tout ça et à chaque fois on
veut dire on me nomme par un prénom qui
n'est pas le mien donc ça peut être
marie julie mélanie alors que en
l'occurrence j'ai besoin d'un prénom qui
est cassé quand il pas très banale et
classique wii bénédicte on retient en
général et je me dis bon là ça fait toi
un peu beaucoup il ya dû avoir un et six
des sept semaines d'audience
quand on voit là je me retrouve rappelé
jean-marc vous êtes des problèmes voilà
j'ai donc là je me dis ça c'est bizarre
moi je ne suis pas très à l'aise et le
jt comment saint patrick arrive vraiment
presque une minute avant la prise
d'antenne et le jt commence
donc et entrent donc et entre chaque
sujet quand entre sac chaque bon quand
il fait ses lancements voilà oui il ya
des reportages ou et voilà pour moi là
donc il me fait un peu des choses assez
complices quel monde tu veux que je dis
misa
voilà des petits clins d'oeil comme ça
et moi je suis vraiment sous la coque
je trouve que le témoignage de lacroix
parce que bénédicte c'est le premier
témoignage on a ou bénédicte en fait
elles sont totalement c'est ça qui me
fait rire et c'est pour ça qu elle n'est
pas du tout de fascination ou rythmique
si en fait c'est ça en fait là elle est
au contenu d'autres témoignages de deux
jeunes filles voilà deux femmes voilà
qui était acquise et qui était très fan
voilà donc bon elle c'est ça qui est
drôle c'est que tous les gestes se
limite ici venu en fait c'est ça c'est
assez drôle et c'est c'est vraiment un
autre type de témoignage que c'est la
première fois qu'une présumée victime
ont eu à dire présumés voilà et à cette
distance avec avec avec bd avec la
télévision avec voilà donc vous vous
avez écrit votre libre mais c'est votre
truc et puis après bon lit-on voilà c
est pas la recherche de la gloire non là
de ma lancée alors j'avais écrit mon
livre je ne pensais même pas le publier
je veux dire c g ça a été une espèce de
d'édition express
où j'ai eu tout d'un coup voilà
géraldine pas en témoigne à l'époque
tout de même j'ai eu une longue le
paquet et ça m'est tombé dessus moi je
pensais pas du tout publier ce livre et
je me suis retrouvé en l'espace de six
mois dans un milieu qui n'était pas
celui dans lequel j'évolue et alors nous
amener à nous raconter ce qui s'est
passé ce qui s'est passé après géraldine
je sais que les équipes m'ont dit que
vous connaissiez benetton alors il est
édité par la même maison d'édition
flammarion n'avait comme éditeur
frédéric beigbeder connaissez bien je
connais c'est bien sûr bénédicte et je
me souviens qu effectivement quand
seront premier roman est arrivé au
warm-up effectivement elles étaient
propulsés dans toutes les télés taëf
hardy sont avérées avait absolument les
escaut parler de frédéric beigbeder qui
était votre éditeur mon éditeur et son
éditeur et vous on en parlera après vous
avez dit voilà que votre éditeur croyez
pas cette histoire voilà à moi je n'ai
pas dit c'est bien donc oui bien sûr
venait alors bénédicte après le
donc après le journal se termine voilà
donc le générique de fin pendant le
générique de fin même patrick quitte le
plateau sans un regard son assistant de
vienne me chercher en me disant qu'il
est parti se démaquiller et qu'elle mène
dans son bureau qu'il arrive rapidement
donc je prends avec son assistante un
ascenseur et je m'entends à un étage de
traverse un énorme open space et au bout
il y a le bureau de patrick poivre
d'arvor
elle me fait asseoir sur une des chaises
devant le bureau de patrick poivre
d'arvor et elle me dit il arrive bientôt
et il s'est passé presque une demi heure
où je suis seul à cet endroit quand même
deux mineurs en l'occurrence où je peux
entendre et apercevoir que l'open space
se vide parce que les gens bas ont fini
leur journée et rentrer chez eux
donc je me retrouve à maman vraiment
seul et patrick arrive quand le laitage
est complètement vide
il se déchausse ferme la porte et tout
d'un coup
voilà il est
comme si on était des vieux amis voilà
il bénit en chaussettes à autre chose
est pas hyper sexy
alors donc qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
fini dit
mais faire un petit peu le tour du
propriétaire il me montre la formidable
vue qui est là en haut de la tour tf1
sur paris
il me montre la bibliothèque avec des
photos on va dire un peu trop fait de
lui avec des gens importants des
présidents donc ça peut être bill
clinton yasser arafat il s'attarde pas
mal sûr même beaucoup sur une photo de
solenn s'assure
il me propose de boire de l'alcool moi
je ne bois pas néanmoins lui se met à en
consommer et
la discussion il assis derrière son
bureau se lancent un peu sûres bah voilà
pourquoi j'écris
[Musique]
et
voilà des choses qu'elles sont mais
thème qu'est ce que je lis mentionne
tout une discussion on va dire assez
classique qui commence à dévier à un
moment parce que donc quelques jours
avant en fait j'avais fait nos missions
donc tout le monde en parle d'ardisson
ou thierry ardisson
avait
balancé sur le plateau en fait
mon petit ami de l'époque
donc un moment tout même extrêmement
gênant en lui posant des questions
particulièrement déplacés qui avaient
fait rire tout le plateau et baffie et
tout le monde et qui est ce qu'ils
avaient fait qu'en fait mon ami était
parti
sans vouloir répondre parce que c'était
particulièrement déplacée patrick me
fait référence à cet épisode et me
demandent en fait comment j'ai arrangé
le coup avec mon copain s'il est jaloux
voilà il me pose également donc là je me
dis bon me pose la question à savoir
aussi pourquoi je suis dit tu es dans
une grande maison d'édition comme
flammarion et en l'occurrence si j'ai
des contacts
600 sens voilà c'est de savoir si vous
avez quelqu'un qu'on fait ils me
demandent également si j'ai couché avec
mon éditeur a directement voilà el-awady
sait comment ça une des questions toi
même un peu bizarre malgré tout je
réponds parce que je suis bien élevé et
et la voilà la discussion continue à en
fait à briller
quand il se met à parler de mon poids
alors oui c'est seriez vous parle de
votre bouaké où il dit qu' il est vrai
vous aider à vous nourrir
voilà qu'en fait
il est très sensible aux filles qui sont
une grande minceur voire d'une maigreur
en l'occurrence me demande si je suis
anorexique
et et qu'en l'occurrence les filles
anorexiques sont souvent très fine très
sensible et que le connaît
particulièrement bien le sujet pour
avoir était père d'une fille anorexique
qu'il était et est donc
donc voilà en fait là je me dis ça ça va
plus trop et pendant tout ce moment en
fait où la discussion vraiment des vies
vrille
patrick parle de goût en marchant dans
son bureau il tourne autour de son
bureau il tourne autour de ma chaise et
à un moment quand il est derrière moi me
saisit en fait comme ça avec une clé de
bras je bascule en arrière avec lui sur
le tapis et nous ton
d'un cran alors
c'est vrai que vous n'arrivez pas
décrire la scène libération a relaté le
récit de de votre agression visuelle des
puits et donc ils tournent autour de
vous et alors qu'il est derrière elle la
saisie par la gorge en lui faisant une
clef de bars que nous avait dit elle
bascule ils se battent par terre il
remonte sa jupe il l'embrassé son
haleine épouvantable la révulse elle
tente une feinte non pas comme ça on
vaut mieux que ça prenons rendez-vous et
elle s'enfuit tandis qu'ils se lèvent
pour prendre son calepin
en fait donc quand on était en train de
se battre au sol et il mettait sa main
dans la culotte qui remonte à ma jupe et
vénitiennes de baisser mon collant
j'ai vraiment eu à un moment je me suis
dit pas moi pas moi je veux pas et
est en fait j'ai voyagé
j'ai repoussé d'une main son visage
j'étais donc qui m'embrassait de force
et je lui ai dit patrick g minauder fait
dire méritons mieux que ça de manière
plus jolie je me suis dit voilà essaye
de t'en sortir par la feinte à nature
parce que de toute façon il allait la
force physique pour lui il aura de toute
façon c'est si c'est un homme moi je
pèse 40 kg donc c'était la feinte il
s'est levé aussitôt et donc l'a voulu il
a attrapé son carnet pour pour fixer un
rendez vous et même moi je suis partie
en courant je pris mes affaires je suis
parti en courant dans un couloir sans
lumière voilà en attendant l'ascenseur
en ayant peur qu'ils me rattrape tout
vous dites après dans la dans
l'ascenseur quand vous retournez chez
vous sur le chemin du retour vous dit
quoi sur le chemin du retour vous déjà
j'attendais une demi heure un taxi parce
qu'on est en 2003 y avait pas deux
donc là vous cogiter j'ai parti revienne
ouais j'ai parti revienne
[Applaudissements]
voilà je suis sous le choc
je suis sous le choc oui vous en parler
à quelqu'un tout de suite vous appelez
quelqu'un vous non pas du tout on en
parle à personne
personne vous rentrez chez vous vous
faites vous en parle à personne à
l'époque je vivais chez ma mère d'accord
et je faisais vous que
24 25 ans
on n'a pas envie de parler de ça avec sa
mère tu ça on va pas venir du club donc
là vous voilà vous êtes vous êtes chez
vous vous
vous sentez forcément mal vous n'en
parlez à personne la nuit vous y pensez
toute la nuit ou dit euh je me souviens
pas là pour le coup c'est à 19 ans je
m'en souviens pas je sais que je sais
que quelque chose de grave et d'un
normal s'est passé j'ai conscience
d'être passé à côté de quelque chose de
terrible mais c'est vraiment mal à sidi
futur alors
vous en parlait ensuite à flammarion
autres éditeurs donc vous en parler à
qui chez flammarion
je me rends au nord le bureau de
frédéric beigbeder
était votre éditeur qui était mon
éditeur donc voulu dire le jour ouvert
juste après pardon vous lui dites moi je
lui dis que je vous dis mais attend
bonjour donc je suis allé au jt de ppda
il m'a littéralement sauté dessus il est
fou voilà et je commence à raconter mon
histoire et frédéric
ri de son rire tonitruant que géraldine
doit connaître il explose de rire comme
ça rien n'est grave voilà et
[Musique]
ben en fait je suis
je suis sidéré je suis sidéré de sa
réaction
houellebecq est là et
[Musique]
frédéric en fait tu prends michel
houellebecq a voilà parti et lui dit à
marc garde bénédicte voilà les pda c'est
la nouvelle sur qui il est avec paris
qui leur disent parce que qu'est-ce qui
se passe il se passe que ppda essayé de
sauter bénédicte houellebecq aurait
conclu rien au change alors voilà et en
fait moi je suis dans le bureau de boue
et je vois ces deux hommes je ne vois
pas la gravité qui ne défendent pas je
ne vois aucun cours où je ne vois aucune
colère je ne vois personne qui m'ont
défunt donc je m'en vais
je descends vers mon attachée de presse
qui
s'ils me dis tout simplement mais à quoi
tu t'attendais
tu à 25 antennes jolie fille tu viens
d'écrire un livre ppda est un passage
obligé
alors deux ans plus tard vous recroiser
pu dire dans un lobby d'hôtel vous êtes
avec un enfant endormi sur vos genoux et
à qu'est-ce qui vous dit
alors il ya tout un
c'est voilà le tout un contexte en fait
dont je peux pas trop parler par rapport
à l'anc est bien sûr ça se passe à
londres je rends visite à une amie
1 pour l'inauguration d'un hôtel
ppda se trouve là il s'avère que
les proches d'elle
et donc moi je vois je elle décide alors
que je l'avais averti à maintes reprises
le petit était ppda il avait débuté une
relation après moi voilà les gens font
ce qu'ils veulent
néanmoins voilà elle décide de passer la
nuit avec lui et elle était là avec son
enfant et moi je me dis je lui dis que
je rentre à chelsea à l'appart avec son
fils si elle veut rester avec patrick
poivre d'arvor et elle a aussi donc je
me retrouve dans ce lobby d'hôtel à
trafalgar square avec avec un enfant de
9 ans qui s'endort il est très tard et
les taxis n'arrive pas et c'est très
long et tout d'un coup vraiment jeu
derrière moi des derrières les plantes
vertes il ya j'entends la voix de
patrick poivre d'arvor avec la noix tout
même très particulière qui me dit
bénédicte nous pouvons reprendre nous en
étions restés et donc je sursaute
l'enfant se réveille et il l'a fait fuir
en en l'insultant
il donne la répartition oui
mais c'est incroyable et donc oui dans
les témoignages de bénédicte il est
bouleversant il ya des détails qui
posent question puisque on se demande si
tf1 était au courant ce soir vous
n'aurez données qui avait quand même une
assistante qui vous emmener sur le
plateau qui vous emmener à son bureau
non qu'ils n'étaient pas seuls et qui
visiblement on devait assister tous les
soirs à ce spectacle est un vrai mode
opératoire et l'autre chose qui ressort
apparemment au delà du fait que les
agressions auraient lieu dans son bureau
c'est qu'il faisait miroiter à chaque
fois des opportunités professionnelles
aussi longtemps que j'attendais bien non
rien de sa part mais oui je pense que
mes appris pendant blanche alors
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la
justice alors juste avant de rentrer en
plateau j'entendais que vous évoquez le
côté sérielle oui et ce serait vraiment
bien que la justice le fasse pour la
faire ppd là parce que nous sommes des
dizaines et des dizaines de femmes qui
avons soit porté plainte soit témoigner
de manière anonyme ou
à découvert qui souffrent on n'est sûr
de ne pas être suffisamment entendu qui
souffrons de de sa morgue de son dédain
voilà de son mépris
envers nous
il continue à porter beau à se faire
inviter moi je parle je souffre à chaque
fois quand je le vois en une par exemple
je prends le train cet été avec mon fils
on les achète il est en couverture de
voici à la plage je souffre je suis
invité à un salon du livre il est
président d'honneur je souffre je me dis
non ce n'est pas possible donc
la prescription en france fait que les
faits sont trop vieux pour pierce a jugé
donc loup ce qu'on attend c'est un
procès si qu'ils sont entendent aussi
qu'il se tienne devant le juge et que la
justice après fasse son travail
mais il faut aller jusqu'au procès un
tel comportement ce n'est pas un délit
ce n'est pas de la drague lourde c'est
un c'est un crime
girardi je suis très touché par ce que
raconte effectivement bénédicte et puis
moi je me repens ce mois jeune
romancière parce que vous étiez dans la
même maison d'édition mais maison
d'édition invité aussi pour vol de nuit
avec ppda je vais raconter aussi ici
maintes fois effectivement je suis après
l'émission et jeannot romancière
d'angoissé et encore il ya plus
longtemps que toi et effectivement moi
il me poursuit à la fin des missions et
les raconter ici entre les deux portes
battantes je suis donc tout seul avec
lui et il me dit vous me plaisait
beaucoup j'adore votre roman le même
mode opératoire que tu décris de manière
très pressante il est très pesant comme
ça et puis je dis bah écoute et en plus
il faut qu'on se revoie je dis
maintenant on se reverra pour mon
prochain livre en fait je dégage et je
lui mets une sorte de râteaux comme ça
et effectivement voilà je me dis que par
cette réponse là et par voilà mon âge ma
défense et ma force à ce moment là j'ai
peut-être aussi éviter peut-être un
drame ont pas voilà donc je
c'est vrai que
je me dis que ça se joue aussi à peu de
choses aussi de basculer dans voilà dans
un bain dans un drame intime qui rend
très touchant merci géraldine et surtout
merci bénédicte avoir été avec nous ce
soir merci d'avoir trouvé la force de
vous exprimer en direct je pense que
c'est important je voulais justement le
fait de ne pas être anonyme je pense que
derrière le mot viol il faut que chacun
réalise que sont des femmes conte et de
voilà qu'on essaie de chair qu'on
souffre tout con et des mères qu'on est
10h qu'on est des filles et qu' il ya un
bonhomme qui s'en est pris à nous de
manière sérielle au même endroit de la
même manière et qu'on a tout le même
profil